comment les français connaissent style
leur code de la route c'est pour avoir
la réponse à cette question que la
prévention routière organisé une journée
d' enquête auprès de tous les français
volontaires pour ré qu'on répondra une
petite interrogation quelle précaution
monsieur doit prendre le conducteur d'un
véhicule en tout en stationnement
en quittant un stationnement sont donc
ils font tourner à droite ou à gauche
il doit d'abord prendre la précaution de
mettre sa flèche vérifier si au dépô t
au et son numéro 40 pour quelle
catégorie d'usagers le port du casque
est il obligatoire pour tous les
les vélos moteur d'une cylindrée
supérieure à 50 cm oui et puis enfin
tout ce qui est supérieur à ce qui est
supérieur à 50 centimes sa bille august
d'agglomération ou en dehors des
agglomérations
vous avez gagné le suspect est allé
rhabiller je vais vous demander votre
nom me paraissent monsieur bresse le
code de la route vous fait il une
obligation lorsque vous produisez de ne
jamais être gêné dans vos possibilités
de mouvement et votre champ de vision
soit par les passagers ou soit par les
objets transportés
cette dernière question numéro 3 à
quelle distance doivent être visibles le
dispositif réfléchissant placé à
l'arrière d'un véhicule lorsqu'ils sont
éclairés par les feux de route
vous êtes sûr
rouge est visible à 150 mètres et les
quelquefois fin d'année que je pense
n'ont jamais voulu répéter la question
à quelle distance doivent être visibles
les dispositifs réfléchissants placé à
l'arrière d'un véhicule lorsqu'ils sont
éclairés par les foudres août
ne confondez pare feu rouge et
dispositifs réfléchissants
en fait on me dira monsieur à une
intersection
muni d'un panneau stop ou doit-on
marquer un temps d'arrêt jean fox et
environ 100 mètres avant absolument pas
c'est à la limite de l'intersection
monsieur contre se former
la question 19 quelle est d'après le
code de la route la définition d'un
pneumatiques en bon état ces cartes ne
m'a dit qu'une présence au filet
par les traces de
douala jean dessous et b
les structures soient
bien avare en bas
oui c'est bon monsieur c'est bon mais
chez le commissaire ce soir environ
trois cent mille personnes seront passés
par les 400 postes comme celui ci
installé par la prévention routière dans
toute la france il est évidemment trop
tôt pour retirer une statistique général
de ces examens mais
pouvez vous me dire qu'elles sont d'une
part les
l'usager qui se prête à subir des
examens et d'autre part quels sont leurs
réponses je veux dire est ce que les
français semblent connaître leur code de
la route est bien en ce qui concerne la
qualité des gens qui sont subi ce test
sur les connaissances du code de la
route sur paris tout au moins nous
touchons diverses la société j'ai
constaté ce matin par exemple que nous
avions énormément d'usagers de deux
roues
les cyclistes eux-mêmes des cyclistes de
presse mines dont l'érudition d'un
d'entre eux mêmes d'ailleurs sidéré
puisqu'il a non seulement répondu
correctement aux questions mais la même
cité mes numéros des textes d'autre part
nous pensons tout de même d'une façon
plus générale obtenir dans ces
conditions-là la certitude de plus les
gens connaissent leurs codes d'une façon
presque réflexe favorise que je veux
dire les centres vous donner un chiffre
sur ce qui sera passé ce soir
et quels seront les résultats est
évidemment prématuré mais je pense quand
même que nous obtiendrons grâce à
l'action de prévention routière et à
notre effort ici
un sondage certains et une prise de
connaissance par le public des
nécessités du code de la route et de
l'obligation de respecter et que sa
connaissance permettra entre autres de
mieux circuler dans paris c'est un
problème que ça
cette interview c'est que la circulation
dans paris est bon c'est beaucoup sur
les habitudes des usagers et sur les
erreurs qu'ils commettent par
méconnaissance du code ou par une
mauvaise interprétation de ses règles
[Musique]